[Music]
is what I just wanted to get back online
Eric always wants to be online
he's an Internet addict the 20 year old
spends lots of time playing computer
games and in social networks
he realized that himself and now he
wants to end his addiction but he knows
that to do that he'll need help
Eric is on his way to his computer
here's Kwazii here's the monitor the
equipment for the computer here's the
keyboard yes there's a drawing tablet
monitor is here he isn't here is all the
stuff
Mouse cables webcam all the extra stuff
I also do that kind of calm how do you
cope with all this being here to be
honest the moment I've brought it all
into the cellar It was as if a
tremendous weight fell from my shoulders
sure sometimes I miss it and would like
to get back on line but on the whole it
feels good is your school done
maybe he's painting too rosy a picture
because even if his own PC is out of
range
Eric easily finds ways to surf the
Internet elsewhere and then there's
always his smartphone I use it only when
I urgently need it so it's usually here
that's the danger how do you define
urgent you mind if India trusted Inga's
so often do you urge indeed it as if I
urgently need it really maybe once a
week but I use it every few days that's
the crux of the problem how do you find
that not so good eric is moving from the
digital to the analogue world from the
drawing tablet to paper and pencil he
draws comics the main thing don't think
about video games when his computer was
still on his desk
Eric was often online day and night he
lives alone with no one to interrupt him
my record was 20 hours without a break
ok to go to the toilet or prepare food
but I ate in front of the computer
finger I started in the morning and
continued until late in the night
actually
till the next morning the first person
is more my English come a dozen but in
that situation you thought that was okay
otherwise you wouldn't have done it
right yes
no I had already started to ask myself
whether it was really okay and then I
realized what I'm doing here will turn
out badly I have to change something but
I don't have the strength to get out of
this by myself
and to shut this off that's why that was
the point where I realized they have to
get help or I'll go down the drain
thank you for you wonder Erick sought
help at a Counseling Center for online
addicts usually all the seats here are
occupied but the other internet junkies
didn't want to appear on camera home I
had a lot of stress with my mother and I
moved out earlier just 15 at school they
used to tease me and bug me
it was horrible for me and when I came
home there was the PC via deputy da I
played it was a way of escaping all the
unpleasant feelings were suppressed and
it gradually turned into a habit well
that means you had a positive effect for
you at that time you just felt better
because of it I always looked forward to
it in the morning I felt oh I've got to
go to school at school I always thought
just a few more hours and I can go home
and play kept me going through the day
these days Eric has lots of time he quit
school and broke off his volunteer year
working for ecology just to keep playing
even though he now looks for ways to
distract himself from his craving for
the Internet
Eric is still far from clean he still
visits his buddies just to check his
emails okay then let's start this is
Benny they've known each other for years
the problem is Benny is a big fan of
computer games and that gets Eric
gushing again to imagine a marketplace
like eBay or Amazon at steam you can buy
games that you store on your steam
account you no longer have them
physically on a CD they're stored online
in a library a continuous cash budget
and you can access them from any
computer not just at home if you have a
computer elsewhere you can install games
from your account that makes it more
practical over the years I've assembled
quite a collection of games
it must be 40 of them so I'm sure I must
have put two or three hundred euros into
the games so it's not just the addiction
itself it's also the expense which can
ruin you here an update there a new game
the outlays PI line estimator I spent
about a thousand euros or maybe more
more every add-on cost about another
fifty euros and one comes out every year
I know 1500 euros complete thousand for
sure but that's your money you get a
driver's license it sure must be a good
computer game but it's not just computer
games Eric also spends a lot of time on
social networks and video portals
youtubers of YouTube is one of my
weaknesses definitely you can watch it
anywhere in the library in an internet
cafe with friends just click on a video
it's terrible you asked me not to save
you anymore click on a video and see ten
others on the suggestion list and you
click on the next one
and then the next soon you've lost two
hours eric is in therapy what do you
think about that really you're in
therapy you never told me I am
definitely a good idea I wish more that
to be honest you told me you wanted to
stop using a PC altogether and that
makes no sense I mean you have to see
the difference between de deja and work
when you want to apply for a job you
have to sit in front of a computer to
write your application you can't submit
one that's written by hands like my
grandmother did in the 1950s
but Eric still disagrees with penny and
the tendency of the times
and when he draws his comics he even
manages to distract a few boys away from
their smartphones
we are chemists an nice shop
show me your cell phone yeah yeah it's a
bit of a dinosaur but I'm very happy
with it that's a few numbered and what
do you think about everyone else
especially young people walking around
with a smartphone rid of mine a year ago
and I've never regretted it it's
overwhelming how things are today
everyone has one I'm really glad I'm not
five years younger because then the
temptation will be even greater you
can't escape it anymore
Eric wants to withdraw from his
addiction he's serious about therapy and
goes to an addiction clinic stationary
treatment group therapy individual talks
cameras aren't allowed he's released as
cured two and a half months later hi how
was it that's great I already miss my
fellow patients I drew this in
occupational therapy
it shows the contrast between the masks
I show to other people and might inner
life which I try to hide and my name
indium I had to delve into the
difference and
since I've started doing this I had that
feeling that I don't need my PC anymore
yeah about classes and of course it's
not easy little life must have to learn
to be more honest with myself but I want
to order smashed it off so can we have
realised I feel a lot better when I own
up to myself
laughter sometimes it was very intense
Sun cried and done that in a long time
Megaton ups or bond and why one evening
it was all too much for me everything I
had repressed for so long the reasons I
always played online its surfaced again
couldn't go back to that again but at
this moment it was all so much and it
all came out it still feels funny I feel
kind of naked in comparison with before
but I no longer feel this inner pressure
I don't feel as if I need this
distraction this is desperate playing
eric has accomplished a lot and exposed
his innermost self but he knows he has
to continue working on himself so what's
your plan now I want to get to know
myself better so I'm going to go to a
Buddhist monastery for two weeks looking
forward to it then I'll see I like to
study social work and I have to see
whether I resume my volunteer work year
and find another way of finishing
vocational high school that's my idea
for now the computer will stay in the
cellar with guns no completely I've
decided to distribute its parts my best
friend gets the monitor and other friend
gets the drawing tablet I'm going to
give it all away okay good luck thank
you